Hi Dr Peterson,
my question is,
I know you stated in the last lecture
that the importance for setting aims in
life and uh,
to kind of have goals,
goals to work towards.
Right?
So my question was,
um,
what,
where do you,
how do you do that if you don't know
where you want to go because that's kind
of where I got stuck on your,
your future off authoring program
because.
Okay,
that's,
that's a good question.
That's a really good question.
Um,
I think it's echoed to some degree in
the structure of the biblical stories
and in this manner.
So there's this notion in the Old
Testament that morality is following a
sequence of prohibitions.
There's a bunch of bad things you
shouldn't do and then basically you're
good enough and,
and,
and I think there's wisdom in that.
I think that's kind of where children
start,
right?
You,
I mean,
I love children and all that,
but they're there,
they're crazy little creatures and they
need to be civilized.
And partly what you do is you lay
prohibitions on them and mostly what
you're trying to do is lay prohibitions
on them for the behaviors that if they
manifested,
would make their life miserable.
So I have another chapter in this book
that I'm writing called don't let your
children do anything that makes you
dislike them.
And the idea there is that your job as a
parent is to help your children become
the sort of four year olds that adults
genuinely smile out when they come into
a room because that makes the entire
social environment both truthful and
welcoming.
And so your job is to make them
desirable.
Social beings and lot of that is
prohibition.
Okay?
There's this ethical transformation and
it happens to some degree in the,
in the tradition of the.
In the prophetic tradition where there's
a spirit that seems in some sense to
rise above the law,
but there's a real transformation
between the old testament and the new
testament.
The Old Testament is prohibition and the
New Testament is,
well,
here's the good things you do once
you're more than merely prohibiting
yourself from,
from impulsive sin.
Let's say there's a positive good to be
accomplished.
While you might say,
well,
I don't know what the positive good is.
Fair enough,
man.
So,
so this is why this thing that I've said
to people,
it's become this crazy Internet meme,
but that's to clean up your room and
which,
which is a lot better and more useful
than people think.
It's a lot harder to.
But the thing,
the first thing you do,
I think,
and I learned this in part from
Solzhenitsyn when he was trying to iron
out his soul when he was in the Gulag
because he was trying to figure out how
we got there,
how he contributed to how we got there.
You know,
not Stalin and Hitler even though they
were kind of to blame,
you know,
but he wasn't much he could do about
that.
I think what you have to do,
and this is part of humility,
is you have to look around you within
your sphere of influence,
like the direct sphere of influence and
fix the things that announced themselves
as in need of repair.
And those are often small things you
know and they can be like your room,
put it in order because the thing is,
it isn't exactly so important that your
room is an order,
although it is.
What's important is that you learn how
to distinguish between chaos and order
and to be able to act in a manner that
produces order.
And in most households there's 100
things that could be done to just make
it less hideous and horrible.
And so practicing that is a real useful
form of meditation.
And it's also,
it's also,
I think it's a divine act because you're
taking chaos and you know,
if you pay attention even to a room,
it's so interesting.
And I learned because I've,
I've renovated many places now and tried
to make them beautiful.
And one of the things that I've really
learned is that even if you own a
structure,
unless you investigated all the nooks
and crannies and cleaned them up and put
your own imprint on them and made the
mirrors,
they're not yours.
The mere fact of physical ownership
doesn't make them yours.
You have to establish a dynamic
relationship with the objects before
they're actually years and I think you
can.
You can do something as simple as just
sit on your bed and think,
okay,
there's probably like five things I
could do today so that tomorrow morning
is slightly better than this morning was
at least,
or at least I'm not falling behind.
And those will usually be like heavy
data toad in the morning.
Right?
It's like,
it's not going to be something you want
to do.
There'll be things you're trying to
avoid.
There are snakes essentially,
but if you ask yourself like you're
asking someone,
which I think is a form of prayer,
if you ask yourself,
instead of telling yourself,
you know,
what is it that I could do to set things
more right today that I would actually
do?
It's usually some small thing because
you're not that disciplined,
you know?
Then you can go do it and then you put
the world together a little more.
When you do that and that spreads out,
but you also put your.
You also construct yourself into
something that's better able to call
order forth from chaos,
and that makes you just incrementally
stronger and then the next day you can
maybe take on a slightly larger task and
like you get the benefit of compound
interest.
If you do that,
it's a tremendously powerful technique
and they think if you do that at some
point,
instead of just having to fix things up
that are not good,
you'll start to get a glimmer of the
positive things that you could do.
You know,
the positive things that you could do
that would actually constitute a vision
and that that's what I would recommend.
Thank you.
Good night.
You.